[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
big weekend in soccer uh rebecca lowe
and nbc sports premier league host that
show will be at the la coliseum this
weekend the premier league morning's
live fan fest coverage begins at 7 00
a.m eastern good god what time are you
getting up in the morning rebecca for
that
and you got your curls in right now
dad i know you'd appreciate this we've
got a show we've got a show to do today
and it is possibly the world's busiest
weekend and i said to you guys i'm so
sorry i've got like this one window but
i may have haircuts they're like it's
totally fine it's a little bit of
something about mary i think um so to
answer your question dan patrick i am
going to be getting up tonight at half
past midnight for tomorrow's show and
the same on saturday into sunday so
that's exciting
okay explain to the fans what happens at
fan fest
okay so fan fest this is our i think
it's all sick we've done new york twice
dc boston austin miami um so now we're
here in la so we're taking over the area
in front of the la coliseum but we're
going to have all sorts of things for
kids we're going to have everything from
getting an airbrush tattoo to playing
soccer and a nike little pitch um some
huge big screens food and drink um
special guests uh loads of stuff for
families to do and then us doing our
show from the main stage and walking
around interviewing people talking to
people so it's kind of taking our show
on the road and you got the like men in
blazers i think you have somebody from
ted lasso there wait are these surprises
am i supposed to be saying this right
now everyone knows exactly what's coming
up no no we've got uh we've got men and
blazers we've got coach beard from ted
lasso and you might know this but back
in the day in 2014 dan before ted lasso
became ted lasso what it is now it was
an original nbc sports skit that we did
to show our coverage off in 2013 and
2014. so i haven't seen coach beard
since i was in that skit back in 2014
which was hilarious so he's coming on
the show we've got other really special
guests as well and also i think a lot of
this weekend down is about the history
of the coliseum of course the two super
bowls the two olympic games and then
we've got 2028 coming up as well so la
right now for sports is where it's at
i'm told so i'm going to be giving you
history lessons
i've got it all going on
do the english have a sense of humor
about what ted lasso is
yeah i think i think maybe at the
beginning of the whole said last i think
they maybe thought it was serious
because unfortunately in england the
perception of the american soccer fan
about 10 years ago was basically that
now i think with nbc's coverage i will
say
it's changed and if you know anything
about football and american football
fans america you know that to be a
premier league fan in this country you
have to know you have to be an
encyclopedia on your team because you
have to have search out where to watch
it get up at four in the morning you
know you have to be a proper fan so i
think that is changing now and yes now
they're realizing it's just all very
tongue-in-cheek
have you uh have you talked to jason
sudeikis
i haven't not since i did the skit with
him back in 2014 when he walked in the
studio at nbc sports and i was i wasn't
really told what i was supposed to do
and they said um there won't be a script
and i i was like i'm sorry no script no
no you're just gonna follow jason just
go with it and i'm like oh my god i
can't just go with it like he's from
saturday night live anyway he is as you
know so unbelievably talented doing
saturday night i think tomorrow night um
he's so talented that he just carries
you along um what an amazing i'm just so
happy for him and for the whole crew to
have won their emmy and it's just
incredible the whole thing
most intense premier league
fan bases who
most intense well the
the most oh
i i mean i would that quite a few are
very very intense i would say the most
intense rivalry would be the one that's
coming up on sunday which is manchester
united against liverpool they absolutely
hate each other but the special thing
down about fan fest and people in the uk
will be amazed at this is that you can
get man you will get manchester united
fans and liverpool fans side by side
having a beer at 10 o'clock on sunday
morning
the greatest of friends there's no
fighting which is very unlike the
brits when it comes to football so
normally if you get man united liverpool
fans together in the uk you've got to
keep them apart with the police not a
fan fest it's a fanfest are full of love
dan everyone is friendly and loving
uh your crystal palace team is
amazing no not is the answer to that not
very threatening right
well i'm not sure it was ever our
intention to threaten to be honest i
think it's always you've done a great
job a great job of being a
non-threatening team
yeah we just like to exist that's really
good enough at the moment as long as
we're existing damn we're okay your team
are you still manchester city yeah
but i was i was leicester city you yeah
and like one yeah and then they
like
what did i call them the first time i
talked to you i think maybe
yeah i'm just like i'm taking light
chester and you go it's lester and i go
all right i'll take leicester
and then they will do it and then they
won
you and i have come such a long time i
know we have um i i feel like you
shouldn't have left them though you
can't just leave your teams obviously
you don't do that no i did what i needed
to do i gave them a championship
right and now you've moved on okay all
right well yeah
i mean
man city hadn't won and then i came over
there and then what happened
dan you're not doing the reputation of
american football fans oh i'm not a
whole lot of good no do you think i
could be ted lasso
100 yeah that's what i thought would you
be my keely would you be my key
no i would be a rebecca the very
powerful woman who owns the football
club come on i'm i've got to be in
charge of you i think that's how this
relationship would work
uh
cr7 uh how's uh how's the uh how's the
impact there with cristiano ronaldo
well it's never ending um the guy's a
legend the only problem is i'm not sure
the relationship between cr7 and his
manager is as strong as it needs to be
cr7 is basically ronaldo is basically
the manager of manchester united i mean
he is so powerful he is goodness knows
what he's saying in the dressing room at
halftime
the problem is that the manager of
manchester united is not a very powerful
figure oligonosula is just not naturally
strong
ronaldo like lebron
in what way
powerful
yeah i mean i would say he's more
powerful than lebron in the world he's
like top three most powerful athletes in
the world but but with his team like is
he you said he's dictate like oh i see
what you mean
yes i mean yeah i mean i wouldn't say my
mba knowledge is massive but i do know
lebron's got power in that dressing room
yes i mean cristiano ronaldo i would say
within manchester united it could be the
signing and the downfall of the manager
to have signed this guy because he's so
powerful and he's so got everything to
back it up that's the other thing you
know you can only be powerful if you're
bloody talented which he is um so yeah
and this could end up being a great
thing or it could end up being that what
what breaks this manager but who spends
more time getting ready in the morning
you or cristiano ronaldo well i don't
know if cristiano wears curlers in quite
the same way that i do to be quite
honest but it's definitely cristiano if
cristiano was in fanfare at the fan fest
he wouldn't even go to bed he'll be up
all night preening himself ready to go
um
best player in the premier league right
now is
mo salah liverpool striker mo salah who
has scored in the last nine games he
scores beautiful goals he's a i think
someone said the other day he's not only
a great goal scorer he's a scorer of
great goals there's two parts to that
and he's both of those and you very
rarely get that in football he's
probably the best player in the world
right now dan but
um do you have to say harry kane full
name whenever it's harry kane
we've literally had this conversation i
know
we talk about this every year um i i
personally don't have to say both names
when i say harry kane you though i do
when you do it it's great harry kane
that i could be i could be the
play-by-play announcer only for that
just that part only for when he scored
yeah whatever
harry kane all right so you're in los
angeles and what people don't know
is you do an incredible valley girl
impersonation
and
when we did football night in america
you would you would give me the valley
girl occasionally
so how about this i'll just ask you a
question and and uh okay
uh so uh rebecca uh tell me what makes
mo salah just so great
so i really have to curl my hair when i
do the impression it's like you're
really something like that like really
helps to get into character and mo
styler is just i mean have you seen his
hair he's such a sweetie oh my god
uh fan fest starts at 7 00 am eastern on
saturday and sunday
i would wear the curlers
i'd wear them tomorrow just show up and
say here
yeah that's it this is me and own it
yeah
exactly uh so there's coverage on
peacock throughout the weekend saturday
12 30 eastern uh matches on nbc and
peacock anything else that i left out
there
just basically everyone come on down if
you're in the la area 3 30 a.m doors
open get in there oh my god
i know what could go
wrong nothing nothing at all what could
go right
uh i it's great just great to see you
and i'm glad you're doing well and uh
have fun this weekend
thank you lots of love bye guys that's
rebecca lowe nbc sports premier league
host